vraiment alors évidemment il ya eu un
problème au changement de musique voilà
il ya une réception un petit peu
difficile après un triple loop lancé je
fais comme si je me connais sur le
triple beaucoup j'ai posé la main
effectivement ça nous pousse à nouveau
peut-être là la place de vice-champion
d'europe mais on artistique c'est vrai
que les juges n'ont pas pousser non plus
parce qu'au niveau artistique par
rapport aux russes ont été meilleurs
mais ils n'ont pas sorti dès les notes
donc il va falloir encore plus
travailler alors dans les 30 dernières
secondes la visite samedi peut épuiser
le rating
c'est vrai ne dirait pas comme ça mais
parce 43 kg s'est pas fatiguant ouais
mais sans arrêt porté porté away petit
retard sur l'enchaînement retard sur vos
pas que je fais le bec qui s'y colle
patinage artistique a fait en tout cas
tu les mines a terminé le programme
c'est vrai un petit peu en dedans
il est terminée très très fort on a une
baisse de tension à la fin du progrès
les nerfs peut-être déjà bravo mais très
fier de vous c'est plus longtemps que je
passais les époux brunet qui avait de
priape 1h52
alors vite on va encore travailler mais
vous travaillez déjà énormément vous
soyez six heures par jour
vous dites-vous sarah mon programme
c'est pata pata pata pata et kinésie
c'est vrai c'est vrai parce que je crois
qu'il faut une certaine rigueur pour
réussir c'est un sport très très
difficile et il ya que l'entraînement
qui compte et pour moi tant que j'aurai
pas atteint mon but
là je continuerai c'est bien alors le
milieu est très dur un bizarrement parce
que c'est vrai que derrière les sourires
derrière les paillettes c'est un domaine
le patinage artistique contrairement à
ce qu'on pourrait croire où on se fait
pas beaucoup de cadeaux et en plus quand
ils font du foot ou du rugby ils peuvent
faire des grimaces
vous vous devez sourire ces attitudes
doit toujours sourire être bien
maquillée
yann habiller les costumes tout ça mais
c'est vrai que derrière c'est ouais
c'est la guerre aujourd'hui il peut y
avoir des accidents très graves cirque
un coup de patin sur la tête c'est le
coma sarah les enseignants ça peu de
l'amputation
cela peut être une paralysie faciale a
dit mario wii non mais c'est vrai c'est
un lieu non mais sérieux sa muse ça
rigole pas du tout c'est vrai que je
suis tombé sur un portrait il ya trois
ans je suis tombé sur la tête tu es là
l'hôpital pour une future etc
c'était difficile à gérer et
malheureusement je crois que dans une
carrière c'est c1 c'est un sport où on
prend des risques
donc dans une carrière c'est
pratiquement obligatoire qu'il arrive un
accident il faut le dire c'est un sport
où les gens sont pas très sympa entre
c'est un sport qui est hyper dangereux
puis aussi des coups de couteau dans
votre dans votre sport alors tout le
monde connaît la sphère kerrigan harding
évidemment les gens se mettent des coups
de couteau et vous stéphane non mais
c'est incroyable cette histoire un mardi
après midi visite yanis comment ça s'est
passé la veille de du jour peut-être le
plus important de ma carrière sportive
j'ai été agressé dans ma à l'entrée de
la chambre d'hôtel et ça s'est passé en
quelques secondes
et alors et alors j'ai j'ai été blessé
mais heureusement pas trop gravement ce
qui m'a permis de patiner le lendemain 2
et de remporter si vous êtes l'après
midi vous regardez la télé on sonne à
votre porte vous allez ouvrir et à ce
moment là un coup de cutter je pense que
c'est un cutter j'ai pas pu bien voir
mais on a su après que le type avec
fumée du cabanis donc ça le fait
je fait d'avoir dû cabanis soit qui va
vous en parler tout qu'est ce que c'est
ça c'est quand on a trop fumée de
cannabis ont dit cabanis
alors on vous est ce qui est terrible en
plus c'est qu'on vous a accusé d'avoir
monté le coup ouais enfin c'est le
problème c'est je pense qu'on n'a pas
bien maîtrisé la chose c'est à dire
qu'il fallait en parler tout de suite et
j'étais tellement concentrée sur sur ma
compétition parce que les médecins m'ont
rassuré m'ont dit que je pourrais
patiner donc je n'avais qu'un seul but
c'était de réussir mon programme libre
et je me disais qu'après je ferai le
point pour bien expliquer les choses et
je pense que c'est l'erreur que j'ai
faite et j'aurais dû faire une
conférence de presse tout de suite après
on mettre les choses au point alors les
gens ont commencé à dire ah oui on
s'était tu ne lâches c'était avec un
couteau c'est une bouteille de coca
s'était pas de marques à l'antenne dès
jeudi j'ai pas dis kolani cabanis îles
marshall ont donc voilà ouais c'est
l'erreur que ensuite pendant plusieurs
semaines c'était un peu j'étais un peu
perdu quoi c'est normal oui c'est c'est
compréhensible et heureusement vous
aider mutuellement vais très acharné
vous êtes la plus à shanghai est dedans
ouais ça dépend des moments mais c'est
vrai qu'à nice j'étais là pour le
soutenir
je voulais pas qu'on déclare forfait
donc
je suis dit écoute on vit un moment
terrible ok mais il faut qu'on patine
ses vingt ans de travail on peut avoir
cette médaille aux championnats du monde
et il faut y aller il faut patiner et il
a patiné mais ça a été difficile on a
failli vraiment déclarer forfait non
avec son petit cabanis vite stéphane
vous a beaucoup bd dit sarah m'a fait
sortir de mon trouve à celle je suis
devenu quelqu'un ça vous pensez qu'elle
a plus de 2 la niaque que vous je pense
qu on est complémentaires mais c'est
vrai qu'elle a une une soif de réussir
et de toujours aller vers l'avant même
quand tu fais tu n'as pas toi qui les a
loser pas du tout mais c'est vrai que
quand vous quand vous êtes rencontrés en
93 vitier pas vraiment au niveau vous
sortiez d'une d'une série d'essais avec
surya bonaly ce n'était pas très très
bien passé
un génial hein et donc là non c'est vrai
j'ai du mal à mettre au régime syrien
ce qu'elle s'entraînait beaucoup et puis
elle mangeait rien donc ouais mais je
devais suivre un petit peu les mêmes
choses j'ai un gros show avec sa maman
et c'était vraiment pas facile vous êtes
un couple sur la glace et dans la vie
d'alors je peux pas être indiscret vous
savez bien que c'est pas le genre de
l'émission cela dit j'ai mis combien de
temps avant jr vous avez vu patiner
ensemble au début comme ça il y avait
rien entre vous vous étiez servant de
briser la glace
bah disons que c'est vrai qu'on
s'entendait bien et puis un jour ça
c'est ça s'est fait naturellement comme
ava il a glissé il la pénétrait est si
dangereux le patin président est renvoyé
je veux continuer mon histoire parce
qu'il soit tenu compte et muse de
l'histoire d'amour alors ils entraînent
de 10 il est ce que met la main sur la
bouche de laurent jeu le temps que ces
pannes raconte son histoire
voilà et tout et tout simplement on est
on est tombé un mois comme eh bien vous
dites vous ça vous dit j'ai l'intimé
conviction que si on a de si bons
résultats c'est parce que notre relation
intime et forte
donc vos résultats seront bons plus
notre relation intime soit meubles non
mais c'est vrai que mon cette année on
raconte une histoire d'amour tristan et
iseult et je crois que quelque part
notre histoire d'amour en dehors de la
glace nous aident j'apprends à
retranscrire cet amour sur la glace donc
c'est un beau couple un tous les deux
non mais vraiment alors y avait un
problème c'est-à-dire imaginez que vous
disputiez dans la vie comment ça va se
passer sur la glace c'était des images
et ça arrive de se disputer avec sa
compagne son compagnon a disons qu'au
départ c'était une catastrophe c'est à
dire que quand on s'engueulait sur la
glace ou dans la vie courante et bassar
bah oui ça se transmettait et à petit on
met de l'eau dans son vin et puis ça
nous arrive est maintenant à dépasser
sur m6 vous engueuler le matin quand
vous patinez vous arrivez à oublier mais
on vit pas ensemble a envie chacun
cherche aussi des chevaux par an voilà
je sais ça aide un peu quand même qu'on
passe comme une très grande partie de
l'échappée à la quotidienneté de l'amour
en les raisons mais bon ça va bien là
vous n'êtes pas mal quand même
allez pas jingle à c'est un lupanar
cette émission au président franchement
à quoi sert le service public ça sert
vous savez quoi services publics à
permettre du patinage artistique à 20h30
voilà à quoi ça sert c'est sur france 2
dis toi il y avait une question là
j'oubliais une question et c'est un truc
que je me demande tout le temps moi pour
moi chaque fois que j'ouvre un sportif
je pose la question est ce que vous
pensez qu'il faut avoir des relations
sexuelles la veille de le jour même et
ce que le jour même c'est un handicap
non mais sérieux pendant que je dire bah
moi sarah m'avait dit tu arrives à nous
poser cette question avant non moi je
vais vous demander
jamais le jour de l'émission l'émission
jamais je garde mon énergie pour mes
amis téléspectateurs en même temps après
l'émission
normal et vous alors mais il paraît que
ça coupe les jambes alors n'attendez
d'accord alors le championnat du monde
de à vancouver fin mars on va suivre
si vous gagnez vous revenez si vous
n'aviez pas aussi et puis les jeux
olympiques en 2002 salt lake city
et entre temps dans juste après
vancouver je suis super mais c'était non
c'est ça hein publicité tu fais un peu
plus bref tu veux faire ça il veut le
faire on peut réclamer sa fille c'est
l'asie menait la tournée de l'équipe de
france avec tous les grands champions de
france et dans toute la france tout le
mois d'avril du 4 au 20 cette année
oui j'aime bien ça marche déjà très fort
et voilà bah je dis au revoir le deux
amis patineurs on voit à bientôt merci
voilà ta valise vol et stéphane bernadis
le champion de patinage bien